dr oz dr oz is tv host he's running for
senate as a republican in pennsylvania
now
but
there was a video that came out of him
uh making fun of the pro-life movement
and pro-life people this was some time
ago and so now he's being grilled about
this on
fox news he refuses to really give an
answer on when he thinks life thinks
life begins
what is your position as both a doctor
and a senatorial candidate on when life
begins when should we draw the line when
abortion is is legal
as a doctor i appreciate the sanctity of
life and for that reason i'm strongly
pro-life with the three exceptions i've
mentioned that's how i would vote
and when does that life begin
you know again if i'm pro-life then it's
a decision that comes back to the
sanctity of when you think life does
begin and i believe it begins when
you're in the mother's womb
when you're in the mother's womb but
that that carries you all the way up to
nine months of pregnancy
no of course that life's already started
when you're in your mother's womb but
it's a rat hole to get trapped in the
different ways of talking about you we
need as a nation to make sure the
constitution is appropriately followed
and people like me and you may be in the
same camp who are pro-life have our
feelings respected and this is something
that should not be taken away from us by
judiciary legislating from the bench
yeah but that's also something that's
going to have to be legislated and that
answer is going to have to be given
specifically
good on this guy this interview is doing
a great job here that is some weak sauce
from dr oz established titles is your
opportunity to earn the title of lord or
lady in scotland just like me
your humble host lord michael knowles
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land and a certificate established
titles is a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lards or lords and ladies
in english in your title pack you will
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land you can even
get a couple pack for you and your
spouse or loved one of unspecified
distinction you will be able to have
land right next to one another at one
square foot and you will both get to be
called lord and lady you can get this on
your credit card on your plane tickets
you can even put it on your dating
profiles
established titles currently having a
massive holiday sale on top of that sale
you can get an additional 10 off any
purchase you make with discount code
knowles so click the link below or go to
establishtitles.com
use promo code knowles to save an extra
10
today how hard is it to say conception
how hard is it this is
this is the simplest answer this is the
most tried and true answer this is the
true by definition answer when does life
begin it begins at conception at the
conception of life uh it begins you know
uh when does life begin it begins you
know when we decide when we need to have
people make their decision about and it
comes to the question of when does life
begin yeah buddy that's what i'm asking
you what's it when does it begin it
begins and it's a clever answer he says
it begins when you're in the mother's
womb
yeah we all we all agree with that even
the most radical pro-abortion people
i guess with maybe a couple of
exceptions believe that life begins you
know at least by the day before birth
when you're in the mother's womb so when
though when when does it be well you
know in it
uh it's already begun it you know okay
well
so say so just say it
say consent but he can't say it
even john mccain would say it john
mccain who is
you know a little on the squishier side
when it comes to conservatism
john mccain said it during his
presidential race he said i believe life
begins at conception why is it so hard
for dr oz maybe because dr oz doesn't
really believe it
we are in a moment right now where we
are moving the overton window where we
are aggressive where conservatives are
actually making substantial wins
we're stopping woke we're doing the stop
woke act we're making big wins don't
settle for squishes folks hey i'm glad
you liked that clip but hold up
ring that bell please
that would be great i'd appreciate it
get the notifications you won't miss an
episode and if
some of our friends
do have you miss an episode in the big
tech world head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcast subscribe to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you